she is lovely yes but so young
season four of the crown has been the
most controversial yet
with creator peter morgan admitting that
some of the stories depicted stray away
from the truth
the past three seasons have stayed quite
true to history so let's have a look at
what they depicted honestly and where
they skewed away from the facts this
time around
this season depicts prince charles
finding diana dressed as a shrub from a
school production of shakespeare's a
midsummer night's dream
this is a complete disaster as cute as
this was
the truth is they were actually
introduced at a party at althorp estate
by diana's older sister sarah
they then met again at a house in sussex
and after that they began dating
leading to their engagement in 1981.
in the crown they show diana choosing
her engagement ring from a selection of
many beautiful pieces
this one's lovely this is quite accurate
diana did choose the gorgeous diamonds
and sapphires that made her legendary
ring
however the location wasn't so accurate
the show had diana picking out her ring
at bergly house
when really she made the decision at
windsor castle in real life
the engagement ring was given to her son
prince harry after the princess
tragically passed away
he then passed it on to his brother
prince william to propose to kate
middleton with
the queen has some of the top security
in the world
so it comes as quite the shock to see a
strange man breaking into the queen's
bedroom during the fifth episode
in the queen's bedroom in the middle of
the night the show was right about this
a man named michael fagan did in fact
manage to break into buckingham palace
and surprise the queen in her room
fagin had actually managed to make his
way past the high security and into the
palace
twice on the second occasion making it
all the way to the queen
what the crown got wrong was the
10-minute conversation they depicted
between the two
what your toothbrush in reality
the queen was understandably shocked and
scurried out of her room to find help
this did actually happen and as
mentioned before
sarah is the one who introduced diana to
prince charles the two dated in 1977
when sarah was 22 and the prince was 28.
it wasn't quite the best match though as
lady sarah said that while she enjoyed
dating the prince
she never imagined marrying him ouch
this season portrays prince charles
receiving a harsh letter from his great
uncle
lord louis mountbatten in the letter he
writes that he is a shame and
disappointment to the family for
continuing to entertain the idea of a
relationship with camilla parker-bowles
who was married at the time there is no
evidence to prove that this letter ever
existed
and the show's creator peter morgan has
admitted to the fact that he made up
this detail
his defense for the falsity is that he
believes that's how lord louis
mountbatten felt and that he could have
written a letter saying the same things
in a scandalous moment in episode 3.
princess diana stumbles upon a design of
a bracelet with the letters
g and f engraved on it this
is mostly true except in reality diana
found an actual bracelet
not just a design with the same
engraving this is wildly upsetting to
diana as before this
camilla explained to her that she and
prince charles called each other
gladys and fred the crown did stray away
from the truth a bit here
as kimila was never actually the one to
tell diana about the nicknames
the princess found out through prince
charles's friends and a note she once
discovered
right further it is not confirmed that
their nicknames for each other were fred
and gladys
according to author jonathan dimbleby
the letters g
and f actually stood for girl friday a
nickname prince charles had for camilla
this season portrays a very tense
relationship between the queen and the
prime minister margaret thatcher
oh is that while it made for some juicy
scenes
this just wasn't the case first off
according to a biography on queen
elizabeth written by sally bettle smith
the queen did not offer advice or
opinions to the pm
and did not get involved with political
parties secondly the two women actually
had quite a bit in common they both had
a strong sense of their christian faith
grew up during the war and had a strong
sense of duty to their country
while there were reports of friction
between the two margaret thatcher
confirmed in her autobiography that this
was false did princess diana and her
father-in-law prince philip actually go
hunting together at balmoral
the answer is no however the
relationship depicted between the two on
the show is quite accurate
the princess and prince did have a very
cordial relationship
when princess die and prince charles
were struggling during their marriage
prince philip went so far as to write
diana letters in support of her
episode 3 has princess margaret speaking
out against the upcoming wedding of
prince charles and lady die
but he's still in love with the other
one suggesting it should not go ahead
this is entirely false and has been
confirmed by the actress herself
helena bonham carter has explained that
it was her idea to include that in the
season
since season one shared the story of the
downfall of the relationship between
princess margaret and peter townsend
due to interference from the royal
family we can understand why the
princess may have felt some resentment
however the idea that she tried to stop
the marriage holds no truth
another defamatory claim in this season
is that upon returning from a trip to
new zealand australia and the us
prince charles went straight to
highgrove to be with camilla
this never could have actually happened
as when he returned from the trip
highgrove was being renovated
because
i love you prince charles and princess
diana only moved to highgrove in late
1981.
sadly the princess did battle an eating
disorder for a decade
much to the chagrin of the royal family
she even spoke out about it publicly and
said that the bulimia was a symptom of
her marriage to prince charles
episode 9 depicts a wild scene in which
princess die
slips away from prince charles while
attending a show at the royal opera
house and shortly after
appears on stage in a silk negligee
dancing to billy joel's hit
uptown girl unbelievable as this may
seem
it's entirely true in both the show in
real life
prince charles was deeply unimpressed
with this surprise
there were six days that the son of the
prime minister did go missing in the
sahara desert while in the paris dakar
rally
but the crown didn't get right was their
timing the show has her son mark
thatcher
going missing around the same time as
the falklands war the war began in april
1982
whereas mark went missing in january
1982
another dramatic moment this season had
prince charles being caught in an
avalanche and losing his dear friend
major hugh lindsey as a result
tragically
this was a real event the prince of
wales is safe
prince charles was saved from the
avalanche by helicopter but it was still
a very close call
the two royals did in fact embark on a
tour of australia
including a stop in perth the way the
show had diana dressed was very accurate
to the occasion as well
what the show didn't get right was who
actually made the appearance in perth
the fact is this event actually marked
princess dye's first solo public
appearance
the crown depicts both prince charles
and the princess appearing
with the majority of the attention on
diana instead of being left in the
background
the prince was never really there at all
at the end of the day
it's hard to know what is truth and what
is fiction since none of us were
actually there to see for ourselves
what we do know for sure is that the
queen's communication secretary has said
that
the royal household has never agreed to
vet or approve content
has not asked to know what topics will
be included and would never express a
view as to the program's accuracy
now we're wondering how factual seasons
five and six will be since they strayed
so far this time around
do you prefer the historical facts or
the story netflix is sharing
let us know in the comments below don't
forget to hit that subscribe button and
give us a like if you enjoyed this video
you